how was your house your wife Susan I  love your wife she's cooking for asking  yeah it's so nice yeah she's good she's  good  he looks laid-back guest I've talked to  you in a long time  Kona I've done your show maybe a zillion  times and quite frankly I'm bored come  on you've gotten that relax man Trump  say that to Kim jong-un no I don't think  so  yeah so yeah my wife's doing well we  actually we have a we have a thing  called some creep on the subway is  listening in sure does seem like it  that's why I should have a newspaper my  wife and I have a Hall Pass agreement  you know that yeah sure  sure we could be with somebody for one  night no questions asked but I realized  that when you select somebody you can't  just write their name down a stick in a  drawer and pull it out ten years later  and collect on it because things change  I looked at mine the other day Mary  Tyler Moore it passed away a couple yeah  my wives Bruce Jenner Bruce Kenner  you  [Applause]  you